[Música]
una aldea de 340 almas en los confines
de Benny esconde un delicioso secreto
familiar Land un vistro de pueblo que en
realidad esconde un restaurante con
estrella administrado por la misma
familia durante cuatro generaciones los
Dale
perfecto dos vieiras luego arroz y una
chuleta de cerdo
está a cargo del restaurante ha
recorrido esta cocina desde muy joven
Cuando era muy joven hacía pasteles y
pasteles marmoleados a mi mamá le
gustaba excepto cuando lavaba los platos
rompía muchas cosas así que tuve que
parar primero cociné y luego hice
repostería pero siempre me ha gustado la
repostería Este es un postre antiguo lo
hice para el campamento francés de
postres hace 20 años pero no Así
evidentemente ha habido una evolución
era una especie de tiramisú
reinterpretado con mus de queso fresco
con un crocante de parmesano y una
galleta mojada en café y una capa de
chocolate es un tiramisú diferente Pero
completamente mejorado después de pasar
su infancia en la región El joven chef
partió para formarse en París con gizawa
y Kiara antes de regresar a su región de
Puebla
es cerdo señora molleja de cabrito
mantequilla de alcaparras tagliatelle de
apio y usted señor chuleta de cerdo
ibérico desglasada con tomate con la la
mantequilla ambos acompañados de puré de
papa disfruten Muy bien gracias con
gusto
Y qué vas a hacer debajo debajo
pondremos un jugo de guisantes un poco
cremoso para darle un lado ácido con un
poco de dulzor tiene razón antes fue su
padre Jackie Quien dirigió el
restaurante ahora jubilado el chef nunca
está lejos de la cocina todavía pasa 5
horas a la semana en estas cocinas ahora
completamente relajado
tengo que mantenerme ocupado has visto
el clima para la jardinería hoy y no soy
muy jardinero no tengo que mantenerme
ocupado soy más lento que antes tomo
tiempo para leer el periódico
ya no me preocupo por las bombillas
quemadas los grifos que gotean ya no me
preocupo por eso Yo cocino bien
agradable
y cuando no está ayudando a su hijo en
el restaurante y aquí aprovecha la
oportunidad para visitar a su madre lo
hicieron
somos nosotros Hola Jackie
Cómo estás Te ves bella
llegamos en el 60 sólo estaba el bar y
poco a poco comencé a hacer un poco de
comida casera cuando tenía
representantes trabajadores a principios
de los 80 Yaki tomó el relevo
manteniendo la autenticidad del vitro
familiar nosotros cuando empezamos
continuamos con lo que estaban haciendo
es decir vistro menú diario estábamos
vendiendo gas teníamos manteles de papel
manteles vichy y manteles individuales
de papel encima obtuvimos 14 15 en gotas
Milo con eso
y hasta la estrella de la guía
conseguida en 1989 por este antiguo
miembro de
Víctor familiar se convierte en dulces
en gastronómico con una nueva clientela
fue una locura
atrás quedaron los días del bistro de
Luisiana y sus pequeñas bromas a los
clientes habituales
cuando tenía lugar la fiesta de la
Candelaria hacía crepes para los
clientes del día Les ponían pan francés
atascada por supuesto ella doblaba el
crepe y cuando comías bueno tenías eso
que obtuvo una estrella es una hermosa
historia familiar cuyas páginas más
hermosas tal vez quieren por escribir
vienes a buscar tu comida
buen provecho en cuanto a su hijo
También cayó en la olla Cuando era
pequeño está preparando suave de
cocinero
muestra tu tenedor vivir a la altura del
patrimonio familiar un gran desafío para
el joven
No tengo la misma experiencia que mi
padre mi abuelo sí me apasioné
diciéndome Ellos tienen más experiencia
pero eso es normal ellos tuvieron un
pasado trabajaron en casa sea
reconocidas yo todavía soy un aprendiz
esperando a climo
ahora hacen Las Delicias de los gourmets
que vienen de lejos para degustar la
gastronomía de temporada donde la
tradición da un lugar privilegiado a la
creatividad Tratamos de hacer nuestro
trabajo lo mejor que podemos Y eso es
todo solo somos cocineros y pasamos
platos intentamos complacer a la gente
tanto como sea posible este es nuestro
trabajo con placer lo principal creo es
ser el favorito creo que estamos entre
los preferidos de los clientes una
estrella brilla en desde hace más de 40
años cuatro generaciones de cocineros
han hecho de este encantador bistro la
Meca de la gastronomía francesa